permettez moi un nom du collège léon
blum de vous remercier de votre présence
à villepreux 500 personnes ont marché en
hommage de samuel tati le parcours est
parti de la mairie jusqu'au collège léon
blum pour saluer la mémoire du
professeur d'histoire géographie pour ça
normal dans un dernier hommage à ce
pauvre homme qu'elle avait écrit quelque
chose d'inimaginable au delà de l'homme
qu'il était incarne évidemment le métier
d'enseignant qui est un des métiers des
plus nobles de ce pays un métier de
transmission du savoir en métier
évidemment d'éveil des consciences
ce métier d'enseignant aussi célébré à
voisins le bretonneux réunis sur le
parvis de la mairie les habitants se
sont rassemblés autour de la première
édile alexandra rosetti professeur
pendant plus de vingt ans j'avais envie
de deux d'expliquer comment je le voyais
ce métier c'est à dire on est là pour
former les esprits on est là pour
éduquer les enfants pour leur apprendre
à développer leur sens critique un
réseau ni là encore les habitants ont
répondu présent on peut pas laisser
passer des choses pareilles l'afo faut
réagir dans beaucoup de domaines mais il
ya du travail
on ne comprend pas même pas l'acte en
lui-même on se veut
comme il est dit partout pays de
l'expression de liberté d'expression la
presse en a parlé on est libre de dire
ce que l'on veut
toute la france est dit glacé dehors par
ce geste abjecte envers un professeur à
elancourt jean michel fourgous a
souligné l'importance de l'esprit
critique et de la réflexion un discours
prononcé devant de nombreuses personnes
10 nécessaire qu'une légende que ce soit
des les habitants comme les
professionnels de l'éducation se
mobilisent pour montrer que la france
est passée collecte qui a souffert d'un
siècle à une famille qui souffrent ces
enfants qui jouent près je vois aussi un
enseignant qui a pas pu faire son métier
d'enseignant est professionnel jusqu'au
bout dans les yvelines les
rassemblements continuent vendredi 23
octobre c'est mantes-la-jolie qui rendra
un dernier hommage à samuel pâtit
[Applaudissements]